the kingdom is a metal and you can say I
actually have here a vodka glass made
out of zirconium which was given to me
by a Russian scientist some years ago so
here's a sample of zirconium foils
really quite beautiful elements very
very hard very very tough metal now the
reason why is echo Neum was being
manufactured by this particular guy is
because it is used as the coating or the
so-called planting for the fuel rods in
nuclear reactors very useful for making
tools and cutting devices very very
tough but the cone IAM also has a whole
series of uses the oxide of zirconium
zirconia is used as sometimes as
materials to support catalysts